tired but very very happy that's the
mood of these royal superfans they've
been camping out for days to secure
their prime spot just a stone's throw
away from Windsor Castle we're not allow
tents so we're literally under the stars
out in the wind and the cold is very
cold last night yeah this is yeah it's
the first royal for these sisters they
came all the way from Australia
to see it she's a real person like she's
got the family issues
a couple people can relate to
combined with pomp and tradition the key
ingredients for a modern-day fairy tale
for nearly a thousand years Windsor
Castle has been home to kings and queens
Betty how big is the excitement behind
these walls Oh incredible lots of
preparation taking place as you can
imagine there's thousands of people
involved in getting everything right
everything is timed right down to the
last second of where the Royals are
going to be as usual nobody does it
better than the British Army and the
British people really we really know how
to put a show on for the world to watch
but it's not just the army that's been
rehearsing in the streets a choir of
singers living with or having overcome
disabilities has a special wedding gift
a love song written by Sandra Godley a
gospel singer and a big Megan Marco fan
yes from a diverse background my girl
yes absolutely and it's so lovely
because the royal family have already
accepted her and for a lot of people
culturally this is an amazing occasion
to change direction as it were and for
Harry tomorrow somebody outside of his
normal culture we're all celebrating
that and really wished him the very best
hey Liam Megan love it across the street
from the castle free pizza for the
superfans and also a slice of royalty
doesn't he look just like Prince Charles
it's good cuz you know a lot of young
people are taking interest especially
now Harry's you know Mary Megan you know
he does a great deal with the Invictus
games and she's got many merry charities
she supports and travels I think he's
all we're very refreshing in these in
the new era and finally time for
ourselves to get really close to the
Royals